hello I'm Jason Johansen the homicide
Lieutenant with the Las Vegas
Metropolitan Police Department homicide
section we are asking for the Public's
assistance in solving the tragic murder
of Angel Montano on July 3rd 2022 Angel
attended a social media promoted
birthday party in the backyard of 5100
East Wyoming Avenue which is located
near the area of Wyoming and Nellis
Boulevard
at around 1 30 a.m lvmpd responded to
the residents after receiving multiple
calls stating there were gunshots fired
at the house party upon arrival officers
discovered angel in the backyard
suffering from a gunshot wound Angels
transported to a local hospital where he
was unfortunately pronounced deceased
the suspects are suspects related to
this murder are unknown and are still
outstanding at this time if you attended
this party or had any information
related to this incident contact the
lvnpd homicide section at
702-828-3521 or if you wish to remain
anonymous please contact Crime Stoppers
please help us bring closure to Angel's
family and find the parties responsible
for this tragic murder thank you for
your time